free-agency phase 2 phase 3 who knows at
this point the market is largely picked
over and the Cowboys but you know if not
that there are a lot of high-end centers
in free agency that were available week
ago and I wonder if the Cowboys even
knew about this I'd like to think the
Travis Frederick gave them an inkling
that he wasn't gonna come back before a
week's worth of shopping was done for
interior offensive lineman but Travis
Frederick announces yesterday out of the
blue that he is retiring remember he had
an illness that knocked him out for all
of the 2018 season he came back and
played in 2019 but he made it clear that
every day it was a struggle I could no
longer perform at my highest level
playing well is not what I expected
myself and is not what my teammates
deserve because of this I know my days
as a football player are done I'm proud
of what I've accomplished in my career
and I walk away with my head held high I
remember when he was drafted in 2013
bottom of the round a lot of Cowboys
fans were salty because everybody wants
that sexy pick that guy that's gonna be
a fantasy football phenomenon a guy
whose Jersey you want to buy who wants
to buy a senator's Jersey and I just
remember there was there was just some
general consternation as the Cowboys
were quietly and methodically building
that offensive line and they kept
building and building and building and
it got better and better and better and
now they're gonna have to replace Travis
Frederick who isn't even 30 years old
yet Chris yeah it's a huge loss to their
team I mean as we know the Cowboys are
built around their offensive line their
ability to pass protect dak Prescott
open up huge holes for Ezekiel Elliott
this year which you heard me complain I
don't think he capitalized at all those
yards uh I am interested to know if the
Cowboys had any inkling that this was
coming I mean this is this is a huge
loss now last year was not like his best
year he was solid he was good last year
you know before he had his sickness and
was out of football for a year he was
dominant and special he really was
arguably the best center in football if
not the best but now you know the
Cowboys are in a tough spot yeah to find
the center position at this point in the
start of free agency I go they'll find
somebody certainly but Center such an
important position on the offensive line
anybody knows that but I think you could
argue it's as important as any on there
other than left tackle
I mean think
my call the guys you got a guard the
versatile the first agility you have to
have it's Damon's snacks Harrison oh I
gotta have power to stop him oh and then
the next week it's Erinn Donald's the
Tasmanian devil
and he's doing spin moves and everything
so it's a very special skill set it's
usually the alpha male of the offensive
line and the leader and of course
usually the smartest guy in the
offensive line and that's where it'll be
hard to replace a guy like Travis
Frederick for the Dallas Cowboys I mean
for the folks who may not be aware of
the importance of this Center give us a
feel for what the center actually does
especially pre-snap we see a lot of
waving hands alright we see a lot of
turning back to the quarterback what's
the center doing in those moments yeah
the center is an extension of almost the
quarterback in the coaching staff and a
lot of times he's communicating to the
other four offensive linemen right the
guard and tackle to both sides of him to
give them certain calls for how they're
gonna block because the defensive line
lines up in so many different fronts
sometimes a linebacker comes to have
shows he's gonna blitz so one two you're
what you're saying you see him pointing
around like you see a quarterback saying
hey 52 is the mic
well he's reassuring that and then along
with that he's making the proper calls
whether it's a slide or a MOLLE call or
whatever it may be that they have in
their language he's the one that's in
charge of it and getting everybody on
the same page on both sides so you got
to be extremely quick-witted and be able
to react on-the-fly blurt out orders and
then think about it this way well how
special the job is I mean to snap the
ball and then you got to snap it and
then snap back up and block the guy like
Eric Donald who's as quick as could be
so it is not an easy job and he was
special at it and you know Mike I just
it seems like that year away from
football really took a lot out of them
and he kind of reprioritized life last
year a little bit yeah I also think just
the physical demands of overcoming that
illness and maybe in some respects it's
multiple years before you even get close
to being back at the level you were once
at Pro Football Focus has him down for
one second eight quarterback hits
allowed in 2019 in the four prior
seasons that he played he had one sack
and eight quarterback hits combined so
yeah
of the slippage that we saw Joe Looney
will be expected to step in and take
over as the starting center he filled in
for Frederick in 2018 and the Cowboys
move forward but we have seen not a
rapid deterioration of the offensive
line in Dallas but you know there was
that stretch where they were the
unquestioned best offensive line and now
they're they're fading back toward the
pack don't you kind of have that sense
of the Dallas Cowboys offensive line
over the past couple of years
definitely not as dominant as it was two
or three years ago now I think they did
some good things last year no doubt
about it and still towards the the
top-tier in the NFL but not be you know
no holds bar number one offensive line
in football like they were four to three
years in a row there I mean hey Tyrone
Smith is continuing to have issues with
his body you know each season it seems
like we've got the frederick issue zach
Martin's been a little beat up but he's
still one of the best guards in football
Lyle Collins has been really one of the
superstars of their football team but
yes they have invested a lot into this
offensive line and it's not going to be
easy without Geno Joe Looney he'll fill
in he'll do a good job but he's not
Travis Frederick Frederick can do
special things of that position yeah one
of the challenges for Mike McCarthy new
coach of the Cowboys as he gets ready
for his first season in Dallas after a
full season out of football in 2019
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports